Speaker 1: Radical and repugnant.
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
I guess, wants to ban the pornography site
pornhub because of something related to Hunter
Biden.
This one's really difficult to understand.
Daily Beast has a piece on it.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE wants to ban Pornhub
because of Hunter Biden.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is disgusted that websites
like Pornhub exist and even more horrified
that Hunter Biden may have used them.
Raw Story reports that GREENE shared her newfound
knowledge of the adult film landscape in a
keynote address to the Putnam County, Ohio,
Lincoln Reagan Dinner.
Let's listen to what she had to say about
Pornhub and Hunter Biden.
This is really weird.
Speaker 4: Nine states doesn't want to acknowledge
this biological grandchild won't even acknowledge
it.
And so Hunter Biden is hiding out in the White
House.
Why is what I found out this week, there is
a website he may or may not have heard about
it called Pornhub.
It is a disgusting porn website.
As a matter of fact, it should be illegal.
I can't even I don't even know why it exists.
Speaker 1: Right there against business regulation.
But ban the website.
Speaker 4: Hunter Biden used to have multiple
accounts on this pornhub pornography sex website.
And these are accounts where he can go watch
pornography.
These are accounts where he posted his sex
videos.
Oh, like the ones that are on the Hunter Biden
laptop.
This week I found out.
You want to know why he still has an account
on Pornhub?
Speaker 1: Whoa.
Now, I would also wonder, does he have Gmail?
And should Gmail be banned?
Does he have a New York Times subscription?
Should we ban The New York Times?
This is so stupid.
But the crowd is just enraptured by Marjorie
Taylor GREENE telling the story.
Speaker 4: Where his videos are posted.
It is still live and active.
This is the son of the president of the United
States.
Speaker 1: Fraudulent hunter.
Did someone just say fraudulent?
I want to go back and hear that again.
Speaker 4: This is the son of the president
of the United States.
Speaker 2: Fraudulent?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
What's fraudulent?
Speaker 4: Hunter Biden is the most disgusting,
vile, embarrassment piece of trash.
And that is what is a reflection on our country.
Speaker 1: JS Then in that case, how does
Marjorie Taylor GREENE reflect on our country?
That scary stuff.
Speaker 4: And they attacked President Trump
and his family.
I don't care how people vote Republican, Democrat,
independent, nonpolitical, whatever that fact
right there should be so offensive to every
single American that we do something about
it.
Speaker 1: This political cycle has gotten
so stupid, so, so stupid.
So there's a couple of different things.
Number one, the idea that a low regulation
stay out of businesses way, etc.
A Republican would want a website banned,
made illegal.
And of course, when she says that, it's like,
should it be illegal to run the website, should
it be illegal to visit the website?
They're never really clear.
You know, the website should be illegal because
Hunter Biden has an account on the website
is some of the most specious reasoning that
I can imagine.
And again, to what other platforms?
I mean, I don't.
Does Hunter Biden have a Twitter account?
Should Twitter be illegal?
Because Hunter Biden, in theory, can post
videos to Twitter and he has an account there
and Twitter hasn't even closed it.
I don't know the answer to that.
And it's again, another reminder.
They have their stated principles, which matter
not at all to them when it's inconvenient
and then all of a sudden it's banned this
ban that the other thing.
The other thing I want to mention is I continue
to get emails about why am I not talking about
Hunter Biden?
What do you want me to say about Hunter Biden?
The images that were not allowed on Twitter
around the time of the 2020 election were
images, sexually explicit images that were
being published without Hunter Biden's consent.
That's illegal in most states and against
Twitter's terms of service.
Now, if you want to make the argument that
were those images not part of the articles
that were being posted, the articles should
have been allowed.
I'm with you.
And in fact, as I mentioned earlier, I just
finished recording an episode with Lex Friedman
for his podcast.
And the topic of Hunter Biden came up and
we talked about it a little bit.
You know, at this point, it's like, do you
still not have the evidence to charge Hunter
Biden for all of the crimes he supposedly
committed?
If he's committed crimes, go ahead and charge
him.
I don't know anyone on the left who would
say no, he must be protected or whatever else
the case may be.
The fact that it has been this long.
And Rudy Giuliani had the hard drive.
Tucker had the hard drive and got lost in
the mail and the blind computer guy had the
hard drive and all these different things.
And there's still no evidence of any criminality,
of any substance.
Maybe he didn't really commit crimes.
I don't know.
But I have no issue whatsoever with Hunter
Biden being investigated, charged, prosecute,
whatever to the fullest extent of the law.
But there's nothing else for me to say about
it at this point in time, given the fact that
there doesn't seem to be evidence that he
committed any crimes and certainly he has
no involvement in the Biden administration.
So that's where I am on the Hunter Biden stuff.
We'll do a deeper conversation on it on the
next Friedman podcast because because Lex
brought it up.
All right.
So that'll be released in the next few days.